Is it me or do you have a good ear? Maybe it's just an impression, but Chantaine relaxes the sound of people who talk to you about super captivating topics for hours. It's good because I have something really interesting for you. The first mobility service by subscription to the country offered by the mobile audience. Yes, of course. At start, you can subscribe to your 5G forfeits without being attached. Mobile audience.
是我个人的错觉，还是你的耳朵真挺灵的？也许这只是个错觉，不过尚泰（Chantaine）播客里那些跟你聊着超级迷人话题的人的声音，听上去能让人放松好几个小时。正好，我这儿有个对你而言非常有趣的消息。移动观众（Mobile Audience）在全国推出了第一项按订阅付费的移动服务。是的，当然。一开始，你就可以无合约地订阅你的 5G 套餐。移动观众。
To you, the difference. Or on our website. An industrial harbour city that operates as a central point for the outlying semi-rural communities. Six kilometres north of Ubelingen is an inland village called Alvingen, home to a population of around 3,000 people. Acres of farmland, grassy meadows and fruit orchards surround the small township, framed by rolling hills covered in dense fir and oak tree forests. As night fell on July 1, 2002, the quiet streets of Alvingen were disrupted by a deep rumbling from above,
带给你与众不同的体验。或者访问我们的网站。乌伯林根（Ubelingen）以北六公里处有一个内陆村庄，名叫阿尔温根（Alvingen），人口约有 3,000 人。大片的农田、草地和果园环绕着这个小镇，周围是起伏的丘陵，上面覆盖着茂密的冷杉和橡树林。2002 年 7 月 1 日夜幕降临之际，阿尔温根平静的街道被一声来自空中的沉闷轰鸣声打破，
prompting locals to assume an unforecast storm was fast approaching. Seconds later, a deafening explosion unlike any typical roll of thunder or crack of lightning roared across the landscape. Houses trembled as startled residents raced the windows, balconies and the streets to determine the source of the frightening noise. Above the distant forest, a large ball of fire illuminated the night sky. Alvingen resident Stella Wegmüller described the site, quote, The sky was orange-red, flaming, and we saw detonations again and again,
这促使当地居民以为一场没有预报的风暴正在迅速逼近。几秒钟后，一声震耳欲聋的爆炸声响彻大地，这与任何寻常的雷鸣或闪电都截然不同。惊慌失措的居民们纷纷冲向窗户、阳台和街道，试图弄清这可怕噪声的来源，房屋也随之颤抖。在远处的森林上方，一个巨大的火球照亮了夜空。阿尔温根居民斯特拉·韦格穆勒（Stella Wegmüller）这样描述当时的景象，引述道：“天空呈橙红色，烈焰腾空，我们看到爆炸一次又一次地发生，
and we realised it couldn't have been a normal thunderstorm. It was something we had never heard or seen before. Townsfolk watched in awe at what they initially believed was an elaborate fireworks display. It wasn't until burning fragments started to rain down when the chilling realisation dawned. They were witnessing a catastrophe. Ulla Dinkalaka had just finished entertaining guests out in her patio garden when she was startled by the loud bangs from above. Within seconds, glowing pieces of metal crashed down onto her terrace,
我们意识到这绝不可能是普通的雷雨。这是我们从未听过也从未见过的情景。”镇民们惊恐地看着他们最初认为是精心编排的烟花表演的东西。直到燃烧的碎片开始如雨般落下时，那令人不寒而栗的现实才猛然浮现。他们正在目睹一场灾难。乌拉·丁卡拉卡（Ulla Dinkalaka）刚刚在她的露台花园里招待完客人们，就被头顶上方巨大的爆炸声惊吓到了。几秒钟内，发光的金属碎片便砸落在她的露台上下，
smashing through an awning and melting her outdoor furniture. Shrapnel splintered the exterior walls of her home and shattered its windows. Ulla, her partner and their young daughter rushed out onto the street where panicked voices shouted around them. The plane fell. Within minutes, Alvingen's picturesque countryside was on fire. Huge columns of black smoke rose upwards into the night sky, searing the throats and lungs of locals who ran into the fields to douse the spreading flames.
砸穿遮阳棚并融化了她的户外家具。弹片四射，劈裂了她家的外墙并震碎了窗户。乌拉、她的伴侣以及他们年幼的女儿急忙冲到街上，周围满是惊慌失措的呼喊声。飞机坠毁了。几分钟内，阿尔温根风景如画的乡村便陷入火海。巨大的黑烟柱腾空而起冲入夜空，灼烧着那些冲进田野扑灭蔓延火焰的当地人的喉咙和肺部。
They immediately recognised several pieces of the debris, an aircraft tail, chassis and turbines, landing gear and a cockpit with a cracked, bloody windshield. Laying amongst the wreckage were dozens of small bodies. As day broke the following morning of July 2, 2002, the sheer extent of the tragedy that had befallen the German countryside the night prior was fully realised. The once lush and vibrant rural landscape now resembled a battlefield.
他们一眼就认出了好几块残骸：飞机尾翼、机身和涡轮机、起落架以及带有裂纹和血迹的风挡玻璃。残骸之中横陈着几十具弱小的遗体。随着 2002 年 7 月 2 日次日破晓，昨夜降临德国乡村的那场悲剧的真正规模才完全显现出来。这片曾经苍翠繁茂的乡村景观如今宛如一片战场。
Forests and agricultural fields were charred and littered with twisted, fractured pieces of metal. The air reeked of burning fuel and heavy grey smoke lingered under the overcast skyline. Representatives of the German Federal Bureau of Aircraft Accidents Investigation arrived to the scene following reports of an incident that seemed too unbelievable to be true. According to witnesses, two planes had collided in mid-air over Lake Constance. These reports were confirmed when the remains of two commercial aircraft were found throughout an area of approximately 350 square kilometres. Key wreckage had fallen over seven major sites in a narrow corridor 20 kilometres long and 2 kilometres wide. The area was cordoned off to keep onlookers and media at bay
森林和农田被烧焦，到处都是扭曲破碎的金属碎片。空气中弥漫着燃烧的燃料味，厚重的灰烟在阴沉的天空下挥之不去。在接到似乎令人难以置信的事故报告后，德国联邦飞机事故调查局的代表们赶到了现场。据目击者称，两架飞机在博登湖（Lake Constance）上空相撞。当在约 350 平方公里的范围内发现了两架民航客机的残骸时，这些报告得到了证实。关键残骸散落在一条长 20 公里、宽 2 公里狭长走廊内的七个主要地点。该地区被拉起警戒线，以阻止旁观者和媒体靠近，
as thousands of firefighters, police officers and rescue workers surveyed the debris, trying to comprehend the devastation around them. As they searched desperately for survivors, helicopters equipped with infrared cameras sawed above while the depths of nearby Lake Constance were scanned by boats using sonar equipment. Officials considered it a miracle that no one on the ground was killed or injured by the falling debris and that damage to surrounding towns was relatively minor. The first plane was identified as a passenger jet. Luggage was strewn throughout the site and contained clothing, travel necessities and children's belongings.
成千上万的消防员、警察和救援人员则在搜寻残骸，试图理解他们周遭的满目疮痍。正当他们绝望地搜寻幸存者时，配备红外摄像机的直升机在空中盘旋，而附近的博登湖深处则有船只使用声纳设备进行扫描。官员们认为，地面上没有人因坠落的碎片死伤，且对周边城镇的破坏相对较小，这简直是个奇迹。第一架飞机被识别为一架客机。行李散落在整个现场，里面装有衣物、旅行必需品和儿童用品。
Statements from witnesses coupled with the distribution of the debris indicated that this plane had broken up mid-flight, its pieces falling across the land below. The right wing was located in a cornfield and the left was found 2 kilometres out, resting in the garden of a golf course. The plane's fuselage, informally referred to as its body, was split in two, with the pieces landing 300 metres apart. The forward section, including the cockpit, had crashed into an apple plantation. The rear section, including the engines, had narrowly missed an Alvingen boarding school for disabled children, averting what could have been an even greater tragedy. The aircraft's tail was found sprawled across a rural road between two crop fields.
目击者的证词加上残骸的分布表明，这架飞机在空中解体，其碎片散落在下方的陆地上。右翼在一个玉米地里被找到，左翼则在 2 公里外被发现，静静地躺在一个高尔夫球场的花园里。飞机的机身被裂为两半，两截残骸相距 300 米落地。前段包括驾驶舱，坠毁在一处苹果种植园里。后段包括发动机，险些撞上一所位于阿尔温根的残疾儿童寄宿学校，从而避免了一场更大的悲剧。飞机的尾翼则横跨在两个农田之间的一条乡村公路上。
Visible on its sides was the yellow, white and blue logo of Bashkirian Airlines, a Russian airline company. The remains of the second aircraft, identified as a cargo jet, were discovered in a forest 5 kilometres east of Alvingen in the vicinity of the village of Tysersdorf. Its nose was embedded 2 metres deep into the forest floor. Strapped to the pilot's seats inside the cockpit were the bodies of the two men crew. Scattered in close proximity were parcels bearing the red and white branding of international courier company DHL. Most of the cargo jet's wreckage was centralised around the forest, indicating that unlike the passenger aircraft, it did not break up in mid-air. Instead, it remained structurally intact during descent before crashing into the ground.
其两侧清晰可见俄罗斯航空公司巴什科尔托斯坦航空（Bashkirian Airlines）的黄、白、蓝三色标志。第二架被识别为货机的飞机残骸，在阿尔温根以东 5 公里处、蒂瑟斯多夫（Tysersdorf）村附近的森林中被发现。它的机头深深嵌入森林地表达 2 米。在驾驶舱内，两位机组人员的遗体被绑在飞行员座椅上。附近散落着带有国际快递公司 DHL 红白标志的包裹。这架货机的绝大部分残骸都集中在森林周围，这表明与客机不同，它并没有在空中解体。相反，它在下坠过程中保持了结构完整，直到坠毁在地面上。
Notably, the plane's vertical tail structure, used to provide direction stability, was missing. Only a stump consisting of torn-up metal remained. By now, there was little doubt as to the identity of each plane. Two flights had since disappeared from radar, their crews falling radio silent, and both failing to reach their final destinations. In the week ending June 2002, the final bell of the academic year rang out across schools in Russia, signalling the start of the summer holidays. For 45 students from the city of Ulfa in the country's west, the sound of the bell heralded a sense of nervous excitement. For recognition of their excellence in arts, athletics or academics, the students had been rewarded with a two-week holiday to Spain
值得注意的是，用于提供方向稳定性的飞机垂直尾翼结构不见了。只剩下一截由撕裂金属组成的残桩。至此，这两架飞机的身份已毋庸置疑。自此有两架航班从雷达上消失，其机组人员无线电静默，且两架飞机均未能抵达最终目的地。在 2002 年 6 月结束的那周里，俄罗斯各地的学校敲响了学年的最后一课铃声，标志着暑假的开始。对于来自该国西部乌法（Ulfa）市的 45 名学生来说，铃声预示着一种紧张而兴奋的感觉。由于他们在艺术、体育或学术方面表现优异，这些学生被奖励前往西班牙进行为期两周的度假，
to attend a festival organised by UNESCO, the United Nations Education, Science and Cultural Body. The accolades of those who had earned a spot on the exclusive trip varied. 14-year-old Karil Degtyaryev was a prodigy artist. His watercolour and oil paintings were featured in two public exhibitions. Skilled tennis player, 16-year-old Karina Uraslina was accepted into the School of the Olympic Reserve, her trainers foreseeing a gold medal in her future. Passionate environmentalist, 14-year-old Soya Fedatova lectured on the subject of heavy medals as polluters at the Small Academy of Sciences and designed an ecological clothing line made from garbage bags. The father of 11-year-old Artur Kamatov promised his son could attend the student trip to Spain if he earned high academic grades. Artur excelled at school and even won first place at an international mathematics competition.
以参加由联合国教育、科学及文化组织（UNESCO）举办的节日。赢得这次独家旅行名额的学生们所获得的殊荣各不相同。14 岁的卡里尔·杰格佳廖夫（Karil Degtyaryev）是一位天才艺术家。他的水彩画和油画作品曾在两个公共展览中展出。16 岁的网球健将卡丽娜·乌斯拉利娜（Karina Uraslina）被奥林匹克后备学校录取，教练们预言她未来能夺得金牌。热情的环保主义者、14 岁的索娅·费达托娃（Soya Fedatova）曾在小科学科学院（Small Academy of Sciences）就重金属作为污染源这一课题发表演讲，并设计了一个由垃圾袋制成的生态服装系列。11 岁的阿图尔·卡马托夫（Artur Kamatov）的父亲曾答应儿子，如果他取得优异的学习成绩，就可以参加去西班牙的学生旅行。阿图尔在学校表现优异，甚至在国际数学竞赛中获得第一名。
When his father returned home from work one evening, Artur rushed to him with his report card in hand and said, Dad, look, I kept my word. His father proudly responded, Good, I promise you can go. Several of the students were the offspring of affluent, high-ranking Russian officials with wealth derived from their royal rich homeland. For others, coming up with the money to fund their overseas travel wasn't as simple. 15-year-old Arson Masogutov opted to forgo the trip, proposing the money he spent on his father's important dissertation work instead. Arson's father politely declined the offer, urging his son to go and enjoy his well-deserved holiday to Spain. In the weeks leading up to the trip, the students eagerly practiced speaking Spanish and saved up their spending money. Their itinerary included a visit to Port Aventura World, a theme park featuring state-of-the-art roller coasters and waterslides.
一天晚上，当父亲下班回家时，阿图尔拿着成绩单跑向他，说道：“爸爸，看，我信守了承诺。”父亲骄傲地回答：“好极了，我答应你可以去。”几名学生是富有且地位崇高的俄罗斯官员的子女，他们的财富源自他们皇家般富饶的祖国。对于其他人来说，筹集海外旅行的资金并非易事。15 岁的阿尔森·马索古托夫（Arson Masogutov）选择放弃这次旅行，提议将原本要花的钱用于他父亲的重要学位论文工作。阿尔森的父亲礼貌地拒绝了这个提议，敦促儿子去享受他应得的西班牙假期。在旅行前的几周里，学生们急切地练习说西班牙语并攒下了零花钱。他们的行程包括参观冒险港世界（Port Aventura World），这是一个以最先进的过山车和水滑梯为特色的主题公园；
Along with a visit to Costa de Rada, a strip of Mediterranean coastline known for its calm, shallow waters. By late June, the students were counting down the remaining days until their overseas adventure. Awaiting their arrival was the warm weather of southern Europe, a welcome change from the cool to frigid temperatures experienced in Ufa. 15-year-old dancer Sofia Fedotova hoped the Spanish sun and sea would ease the severe back pain that had recently forced her to miss many classes at school. For some of the children, this would be their first time travelling abroad. 14-year-old Dina Shkagimukimetov was looking forward to the flights, as he hoped to one day study aviation and become an astronaut. In his spare time, Dina constructed model airplanes out of plastic bottles and toothpaste tubes, using the batteries of old toys as makeshift engines. Prior to leaving for Spain, Dina wrote to friends expressing how thrilled he was to finally be taking to the skies.
以及参观以平静浅水区闻名的地中海海岸线地带科斯塔德拉达（Costa de Rada）。到了六月下旬，学生们开始倒计时他们海外冒险的剩余日子。等待他们到来的是南欧温暖的天气，这与乌法凉爽甚至严寒的气温相比是一个受欢迎的转变。15 岁的舞者索菲亚·费多托娃（Sofia Fedotova）希望西班牙的阳光和海洋能缓解她严重的背痛，这种背痛最近迫使她缺席了许多学校课程。对一些孩子来说，这将是他们第一次出国旅游。14 岁的迪纳·什卡吉穆基梅托夫（Dina Shkagimukimetov）非常期待这次飞行，因为他希望有一天能学习航空并成为一名宇航员。在业余时间，迪纳用塑料瓶和牙膏皮制作飞机模型，并用旧玩具的电池作为简易发动机。在动身去西班牙之前，迪纳给朋友们写信，表达了他终于能够翱翔天空的激动心情。
The group of students, accompanied by four adult chaperones, departed Ufa Airport on Saturday, June 29, 2002. 90 minutes later, they landed in Russia's capital city of Moscow, where they boarded a shuttle bus to Domodadevo International Airport for their connecting flight to Spain. After arriving to Domodadevo Airport, the group soon realised the travel agency responsible for organising their trip had accidentally sent them to the wrong airport. Their flight was actually scheduled to depart from Cherimetevo International Airport, the two-hour drive to the opposite side of the city. Unable to make it there in time, the group missed the flight. Ufa-based Bashkirian Airlines was quick to come to the rescue of the stranded students, arranging an urgent charter flight. They elected one of their Tupolev 154 Ram series airliners for the flight, a medium-range, narrow-bodied passenger aircraft. Designated flight code BTC 2937, the charter was set to depart from Domodadevo Airport on the evening of Monday, July 1, arriving to Barcelona's El Prat International Airport on Spain's east coast less than five hours later.
这群学生在四名成年领队陪同下，于 2002 年 6 月 29 日星期六从乌法机场出发。90 分钟后，他们降落在俄罗斯首都莫斯科，在那里他们登上了一辆前往多莫杰多沃国际机场（Domodadevo International Airport）的班车，以便转机前往西班牙。抵达多莫杰多沃机场后，这群人很快意识到负责组织他们旅行的旅行社不小心把他们送错了机场。他们的航班实际上定于谢列梅捷沃国际机场（Cherimetevo International Airport）起飞，该机场位于城市对面的方向，需要驱车两小时。由于无法及时赶到，这群人错过了航班。总部位于乌法的巴什科尔托斯坦航空迅速赶来救援滞留的学生，安排了一架紧急包机。他们为这次飞行挑选了图-154M（Tupolev 154 Ram）系列客机之一，这是一种中程、窄体客机。该包机航班代码指定为 BTC 2937，定于 7 月 1 日星期一晚上从多莫杰多沃机场起飞，并在不到五个小时后抵达西班牙东海岸巴塞罗那的埃尔普拉特国际机场（El Prat International Airport）。
As Bashkirian Airlines rushed to organise a crew for the impromptu flight, the students made the most of the delay. They spent Sunday, June 30 sightseeing in Moscow, visiting the colourful landmarks and monuments that defined the historical city and amassing a collection of photographs to show family and friends upon their return home in two weeks' time. 52-year-old Alexander Gross was at home preparing to lay a stone path through his garden when he received an urgent call from Bashkirian Airlines. They requested his presence at Domodadevo Airport to captain the unscheduled charter flight BTC 2937 to Spain. The seasoned captain had flown for many international airlines during his 30-year career, winning numerous awards for his aviation achievements and earning more than 12,000 credited flight hours across Asia, Africa and many parts of Europe. Yet Alexander didn't have much experience with the flight route to Spain or the Tupolev aircraft, therefore the charter presented him with the opportunity to further develop his skills. Alexander accepted the job and hastily prepared to leave for Moscow. His wife noticed he was unusually nervous that day, even struggling to do up his tire. Bashkirian Airlines classified Barcelona's El Prat Airport as an aerodrome in mountainous terrain. As such, pilots making their initial flights to this hazardous destination were required to do so under the supervision of an instructor.
正当巴什科尔托斯坦航空仓促为这次临时飞行组织机组人员时，学生们充分利用了延误的时间。他们在 6 月 30 日星期日游览了莫斯科，参观了这座历史名城标志性的五颜六色的地标和纪念碑，并收集了一批照片，以便两周后回家时向家人和朋友展示。52 岁的亚历山大·格罗斯（Alexander Gross）当时正在家中准备在花园里铺一条石径，这时他接到了巴什科尔托斯坦航空的紧急电话。他们要求他前往多莫杰多沃机场，担任前往西班牙的非预定包机 BTC 2937 的机长。这位经验丰富的机长在其 30 年的职业生涯中曾为许多国际航空公司飞行，因其航空成就赢得过无数奖项，并在亚洲、非洲和欧洲许多地区积累了超过 12,000 个认证飞行小时。然而，亚历山大对飞往西班牙的航线或图波列夫飞机并没有太多经验，因此这次包机为他提供了进一步发展技能的机会。亚历山大接受了这份工作，匆忙准备前往莫斯科。他的妻子注意到他那天异常紧张，甚至连系领带都有些费劲。巴什科尔托斯坦航空将巴塞罗那的埃尔普拉特机场归类为山地地形机场。因此，首次飞往这个危险目的地的飞行员必须在教官的监督下进行。
For Alexander Gross, BTC 2937 would be his second time piloting a flight to Barcelona, meaning he was required to be accompanied by a qualified instructor to oversee and evaluate his performance. The task was handed to 40-year-old Oleg Grigoryev, the chief pilot of Bashkirian Airlines and to the deputy commander of the Tupolev aircraft squadrons. Oleg had years of experience piloting for international airlines all over the world, including Spain, and had recently been crowned Best Air Transport Employee. Due to his superiority, Oleg was effectively in charge of the cockpit, assuming the official role of piloting command, while Captain Alexander Gross was assigned piloting control. Oleg took the seat alongside the captain to conduct his assessments. Typically, this seat was reserved for Captain Gross's first officer, or co-pilot, 41-year-old Murat Ipkulov. But with Oleg Grigoryev in his chair, Murat was considered off-duty and had no official function during the flight. He would spend its duration seated directly behind his superiors, observing procedures.
对于亚历山大·格罗斯来说，执飞 BTC 2937 将是他第二次驾驶航班前往巴塞罗那，这意味着他必须由一名合格的教官陪同，以监督和评估他的表现。这项任务交给了 40 岁的奥列格·格里戈里耶夫（Oleg Grigoryev），他是巴什科尔托斯坦航空公司的总飞行师兼图波列夫飞机机队副司令。奥列格拥有多年为世界各地国际航空公司飞行的经验，包括西班牙，最近还被评为最佳航空运输员工。由于他的资历，奥列格实际上负责驾驶舱，承担正式的驾驶指挥角色，而亚历山大·格罗斯机长则被指派负责驾驶控制。奥列格坐在机长旁边进行评估。通常情况下，这个座位是留给格罗斯机长的副驾驶、41 岁的穆拉特·伊普库洛夫（Murat Ipkulov）的。但随着奥列格·格里戈里耶夫坐在他的椅子上，穆拉特被认为处于休班状态，在飞行期间没有官方职责。他将在上司身后直接就座，观察飞行程序。
It was a worthwhile experience for Murat, who was set to be promoted to captain in due time. Regarded as a level-headed professional pilot, Murat had recently received a thank-you letter from the commander of the Bashkirian Airlines Flight Department, acknowledging his flawless actions during complicated flight conditions. The three pilots were supported in the cockpit by a flight navigator and flight engineer. It was their job to ensure the plane remained on its designated flight path, whilst monitoring the aircraft's systems and rectifying any faults that may arise. Back in the aircraft's cabin, a team of six flight attendants oversaw the passengers. Due to the sudden and unscheduled nature of the flight, most of the aircraft's 166 seats would remain empty. Only seven other tickets were sold last minute to other travelers willing or needing to depart for Spain immediately, bringing the number of passengers on board the aircraft to 56. The Russian student group accounted for 49 of them.
对穆拉特来说这是一次很有价值的经历，他按计划将在适当时机晋升为机长。穆拉特被视为一名沉着冷静的职业飞行员，最近刚收到一封来自巴什科尔托斯坦航空飞行部指挥官的感谢信，表彰他在复杂飞行条件下的完美表现。驾驶舱内的三名飞行员得到了领航员和飞行工程师的支持。他们的工作是确保飞机保持在指定的飞行路线内，同时监控飞机系统并纠正可能出现的任何故障。回到客舱内，一队六名乘务员负责照看乘客。由于飞机的突然和非预定性质，飞机上的 166 个座位大部分将空着。只有另外七张机票在最后一分钟卖给了其他愿意或需要立即出发前往西班牙的旅客，使机上的乘客人数达到 56 人。其中俄罗斯学生团占了 49 人。
With luggage secured in the cargo hold and personal belongings stowed in overhead compartments, passengers took their seats. Pre-flight preparations were completed, and air traffic control gave the aircraft clearance to initiate takeoff. The jet engines rumbled to life, and the plane was slowly taxied into position. By 8.48pm, the Tupolev began accelerating down the runway. Upon reaching the right airspeed, Captain Alexander Gross pulled back the control column, causing the nose of the plane to tilt upwards and onwards into the endless night sky. Bashkirian Airlines Flight BTC 2937 was officially underway. Earlier that afternoon, a cargo-stocked American Boeing 757 jet airliner was completing a standard intercontinental freight assignment. At the controls were pilots Paul Phillips and Brent Campioni.
随着行李固定在货舱内，个人物品存放在头顶行李舱中，乘客们纷纷入座。飞行前准备工作完成，空中交通管制部门向飞机发出了起飞许可。喷气发动机轰鸣着启动，飞机缓缓滑行到位。晚上 8 点 48 分，图波列夫客机开始在跑道上加速滑跑。达到合适的空速后，亚历山大·格罗斯机长拉回控制杆，使机头向上倾斜，飞入无尽的夜空。巴什科尔托斯坦航空 BTC 2937 航班正式起飞。当天早些时候，一架满载货物的美国波音 757 喷气式客机正在完成一项标准的洲际货运任务。控制飞机的是飞行员保罗·菲利普斯（Paul Phillips）和布伦特·坎皮尼（Brent Campioni）。
The pair flew as a team for Deutsche Post Courier Company, DHL Worldwide Express. Flying was a major part of 47-year-old Paul Phillips' life. The British national joined DHL in 1989, clocking upwards of 11,900 in flight hours and earning the rank of captain. As one of the company's most senior pilots, Paul ran a professional cockpit, doing everything by the book. A colleague of Paul stated, As a pilot, if you picked up the plane from Paul and he said it was okay, you knew it was okay. He was meticulous, but he also made you enjoy your job. If you looked at the roster and saw you were flying with Paul, you knew you would have a good time.
两人作为德国邮政快递公司（Deutsche Post Courier Company）DHL 全球快运（DHL Worldwide Express）的团队成员一起飞行。飞行是 47 岁的保罗·菲利普斯生命中的一个重要部分。这位英国籍飞行员于 1989 年加入 DHL，飞行时间累计超过 11,900 小时，并获得了机长军衔。作为公司资历最老的飞行员之一，保罗管理着一个专业的驾驶舱，一切都按规章办事。保罗的一位同事曾说过：“作为飞行员，如果你从保罗那里接手飞机，他说没问题，你就知道它没问题。他一丝不苟，但也让你享受工作。如果你看排班表发现你要和保罗一起飞，你就知道你会过得很开心。”
Paul's co-pilot was 34-year-old Canadian, Brent Campioni, who joined DHL Squadron in 1999. Taking any opportunity to jump into the cockpit, Brent had a massed over 6,500 hours of piloting experience, including 18 months as an instructor. Passion and dedication for his chosen career was acknowledged in a letter of commendation from his employer, honouring Brent's outstanding piloting work. At 11.50am, Paul Phillips and Brent Campioni checked in at Bahrain Airport for a routine freight assignment to DHL's international base in Brussels, Belgium. A flight route the pair had taken many times before. At 1.30pm, they entered the cockpit of their Boeing aircraft, designated flight code DHX611. After departing from the Persian Gulf nation, the pair flew westerly for 5 hours and 40 minutes before landing for a scheduled stopover in the northern Italian town of Bergamo, where their aircraft was refuelled and its cargo unloaded and restocked. Having already completed at the longest leg of their trip, the remaining journey northward to Brussels would only take a further 90 minutes.
保罗的副驾驶是 34 岁的加拿大人布伦特·坎皮尼，他于 1999 年加入 DHL 机队。抓住任何机会跳进驾驶舱，布伦特积累了超过 6,500 小时的飞行经验，其中包括 18 个月的教官经历。雇主的一封表彰信对他的职业热情和奉献精神给予了肯定，表彰了布伦特杰出的飞行工作。上午 11 点 50 分，保罗·菲利普斯和布伦特·坎皮尼在巴林机场（Bahrain Airport）签到，执行飞往比利时布鲁塞尔 DHL 国际基地的例行货运任务。这是一条两人以前走过多次的航线。下午 1 点 30 分，他们进入波音飞机的驾驶舱，航班代号指定为 DHX611。从波斯湾国家出发后，两人向西飞行了 5 小时 40 分钟，随后在意大利北部小镇贝加莫（Bergamo）降落进行预定经停，飞机在那里加油，并卸下和重新装载了货物。在完成了行程中最长的一段之后，向北前往布鲁塞尔的剩余旅程只需再花 90 分钟。
At 9.06pm, DHL flight DHX611 took to the skies once more, flown by first officer Brent Campioni. Shortly before 10pm, Bashkirian Airlines flight BTC2937 entered DHL cargo flight DHX611 collided over southern Germany, becoming the worst civilian aircraft disaster the country had ever seen. The catastrophic incident had claimed the lives of all 69 persons on board the Jubilev, including the 45 school students from Ufa and their four adult chaperones. The two pilots aboard the Boeing had also lost their lives. There were no survivors. The event would later come to be named after the closest major city to where the incident occurred, the 2002 Uberling and mid-air collision. DHL paid tribute to their two lost pilots, Paul Phillips and Brent Campioni. In a written statement penned by the company, Paul Phillips was remembered as a true gentleman without a vindictive bone in his body. His career led him to Bahrain International Airport, where he had a chance encounter with a woman selling raffle tickets named Amy.
晚上 9 点 06 分，由副驾驶布伦特·坎皮尼驾驶的 DHL DHX611 货机再次腾空而起。晚上 10 点前不久，巴什科尔托斯坦航空 BTC2937 航班与 DHL 货机 DHX611 在德国南部上空相撞，酿成了该国历史上最严重的民航灾难。这场灾难性的事故夺去了图波列夫客机上所有 69 人的生命，其中包括来自乌法的 45 名学童和他们的四名成年领队。波音飞机上的两名飞行员也不幸遇难。机上无人生还。该事件后来以事故发生地附近的主要城市命名，被称为 2002 年乌伯林根空中相撞事故。DHL 向他们失去的两名飞行员保罗·菲利普斯和布伦特·坎皮尼致敬。在公司撰写的一份声明中，保罗·菲利普斯被人们铭记为一位真正的绅士，心地善良，绝无怨恨。他的职业生涯将他带到了巴林国际机场，在那里他偶然遇到了一位名叫艾米（Amy）的卖彩票的女士。
Paul didn't win the raffle grand prize of a car, but did win the heart of Amy, who later became his wife and mother of their three children. When he wasn't in the air, Paul lived a leisurely life on the ground, tending to his vegetable garden or fishing in his boat. DHL's statement also commemorated the life of happy-go-lucky Brent Campioni, a sports fanatic passionate about tennis in particular. Devoted to life in the same way he was devoted to flying, Brent found amusement in the smallest of joys, from a good meal to little treasures he'd find on the beach. Next to his home was the dilapidated tennis court where Brent would verse players of higher skill level than his own, enthusiastically welcoming the challenge. His positive energy drew in others, including his wife, Deneen. A friend remarked, ever the optimist, the glass was always half full with Brent. Three days of official mourning were declared in Ulva, with flags flying at half-mast across the Russian city. At the Domestic Airport, a message of sympathy from Bashkirian Airlines was displayed alongside pictures of their deceased flight crew.
保罗没有赢得汽车这个彩票大奖，却赢得了艾米的芳心，艾米后来成为了他的妻子和他们三个孩子的母亲。不用飞的时候，保罗在地面上过着悠闲的生活，打理他的菜园或在船上钓鱼。DHL 的声明还纪念了乐观开朗的布伦特·坎皮尼的生平，他是一个体育迷，尤其对网球充满热情。正如他投身飞行一样热爱生活，布伦特从最小的快乐中寻找乐趣，从一顿美餐到他在海滩上找到的小宝藏。他的家旁边是一个破旧的网球场，布伦特会在那里与比他水平更高的球员对阵，热情地迎接挑战。他积极的能量吸引了其他人，包括他的妻子迪妮恩（Deneen）。一位朋友评价道：“作为永远的乐观主义者，布伦特眼里的杯子总是半满的。”乌法宣布举行三天全国哀悼，俄罗斯这座城市的各处建筑物均下半旗致哀。在当地机场，巴什科尔托斯坦航空的慰问信息与他们已故机组人员的照片并排展示。
At the same time, tributes were pouring in for the 45 schoolchildren regarded as Ulva's best and brightest. Flowers covered their school desks as grieving teachers collected pictures, classwork and report cards lamenting the students' short but impactful lives. A photograph showed several of the female students dancing in pink satin dresses to mark World War II victory day. One deceased student's report card displayed rows of fires. Perfect results. Parents and families were united in grief as they came to terms with the tragic news. Many of them had presumed the children had arrived safely in Spain, only to learn of the disaster over the radio. They wept bitter tears over the ill-fated circumstances that led to their children onto the doomed airliner, culminating from their missed flight days prior. The mother of 11-year-old Bulat Biglov lamented to Russian media, if only they had flown on time. Nothing would have happened.
与此同时，悼念浪潮如潮水般涌向被视为乌法最好、最聪明之星的 45 名学童。鲜花覆满他们的课桌，悲痛的老师们收集着照片、课堂作业和成绩单，缅怀这些学生短暂却影响深远的人生。一张照片显示几名女学生穿着粉红色缎面裙子跳舞，以纪念二战胜利日。一名已故学生的成绩单上显示出一排排的优。完美的成绩。家长和家属们在悲伤中团结在一起，努力接受这一悲惨消息。他们中的许多人原本以为孩子们已经安全抵达西班牙，却通过收音机得知了这场灾难。他们为导致孩子登上这架注定坠毁的客机的厄运流下痛苦的眼泪，这最终源于他们几天前错过了航班。11 岁男孩布拉特·比格洛夫（Bulat Biglov）的母亲向俄罗斯媒体悲叹道：“要是我儿子他们按时起飞就好了。什么事都不会发生。”
Just days before her trip to Spain, 12-year-old Alina Cananova purchased all her textbooks in anticipation of starting the seventh grade later that year. The books remained wrapped and unread on her shelf. Her mother told reporters, I don't feel like a mother anymore. I feel like I've lost my heart. The sister of 14-year-old Ilda Rasila Gulshin would never receive the souvenir teddy bear he had promised to bring her back from Spain. The music box given to 14-year-old Veronica Savchuk for her birthday held a few of her sentimental belongings, a cross, an old coin, and a small silver necklace. These items now cherished by her suffering family. Lalia Uraslina lost her two children in the disaster. Daughter Karina aged 16 and son Ruslan aged 15. The grieving mother asked, What do I have to live for now?
就在去西班牙旅行的几天前，12 岁的阿琳娜·卡纳诺娃（Alina Cananova）购买了所有的教科书，期待着当年晚些时候开始七年级的学习。这些书依然包着书皮，静静地躺在书架上，未被翻阅。她的母亲对记者说：“我感觉自己不再像个母亲了。我觉得自己失去了心。”14 岁的伊尔达·拉西拉·古尔申（Ilda Rasila Gulshin）的妹妹再也收不到他答应从西班牙带给她的纪念品泰迪熊了。送给 14 岁维罗妮卡·萨夫丘克（Veronica Savchuk）作为生日礼物的八音盒里装着她的一些纪念物品：一个十字架、一枚旧硬币和一条小银链子。这些物品现在成了她悲痛的家人所珍视的宝物。拉利亚·乌斯拉利娜（Lalia Uraslina）在这场灾难中失去了两个孩子：16 岁的女儿卡丽娜和 15 岁的儿子鲁斯兰。这位悲痛的母亲质问：“我现在还有什么可活的？”
Alexander Savchuk also lost his two children, 13-year-old daughter Veronica and 12-year-old son Vladislav. In an even crueler twist, his wife, Irina, was one of the four adult chaperones who had volunteered to accompany the students to Spain. The disaster had claimed Alexander's entire family. Emergency visas were issued to the families of victims to allow prompt travel to Germany. They were asked to bring anything with them that would help identify their children's remains, including dental and medical records. Bashkirian Airlines ferried the relatives abroad in one of their Tupolev aircrafts, circumstances that bore chilling similarities to the doomed flight nights prior. Upon arriving to Germany, the relatives were transported to Alvingen, with many still holding onto the impossible hope that their children may have somehow survived. The father of 11-year-old Arta Kamatov stated, We still hoped that these children would run in, appear from somewhere, and probably every parent believed in some miracle.
亚历山大·萨夫丘克（Alexander Savchuk）也失去了他的两个孩子：13 岁的女儿维罗妮卡和 12 岁的儿子弗拉迪斯拉夫（Vladislav）。更残酷的是，他的妻子伊琳娜（Irina）是自愿陪同学生前往西班牙的四名成年领队之一夺走了亚历山大全家性命的灾难。遇难者家属获发紧急签证，以便迅速前往德国。他们被要求带上任何有助于识别孩子遗体的东西，包括牙科和医疗记录。巴什科尔托斯坦航空公司用他们的一架图波列夫飞机将亲属运送到国外，这种情景与几夜前那趟遭遇不幸的航班有着令人毛骨悚然的相似之处。抵达德国后，亲属们被运送到阿尔温根，许多人仍然抱有一种不可能的希望，即他们的孩子可能不知何故幸存了下来。11 岁男孩阿尔塔·卡马托夫（Arta Kamatov）的父亲说：“我们仍然希望这些孩子会跑进来，从某个地方出现，也许每个家长都相信有什么奇迹发生。”
Hope faded when the group reached the expansive and confronting crash site. Although the bodies of the victims had since been recovered and taken away, the wreckage still remained, painting a grim picture of what the passengers endured in their final moments. Dimitri caused several mourners to faint. Makeshift shrines made up of floral wreaths and candles were built around the debris, and flowers brought from gardens in Russia were planted throughout the German countryside. Some grieving relatives dug up handfuls of the earth and picked up stalks of corn from the surrounding crop fields as a somber keepsake of their children's temporary resting place. After a prayer service, an hour of silence commenced as mourners wandered through the devastation, burdened with the unanswered questions, how and why. One parent told the media, We have very many questions, and I think it's the duty of every parent to find out how it happened. Inquiries into the cause of the fatal crash were fronted by the German Federal Bureau of Aircraft Accidents Investigation.
当这群人到达广阔而令人心碎的坠机地点时，希望渐渐破灭。尽管遇难者的遗体此后已被寻获并运走，但残骸依然留在原地，描绘出一幅冷酷的画面，展现了乘客们在最后时刻所经历的痛苦。迪米特里（Dimitri）导致几位哀悼者晕倒。由花圈和蜡烛组成的临时神殿建在残骸周围，从俄罗斯花园带来的鲜花被种植在德国乡村的各处。一些悲痛的亲属从周围的农田中挖出一把把泥土，采摘几株玉米秆，作为他们孩子暂时安息之地的沉痛纪念品。在祷告仪式之后，哀悼者们在废墟中徘徊，开始了长达一小时的沉默，背负着那些未解的问题：如何发生的，以及为什么。一位家长告诉媒体：“我们有很多问题，我认为弄清楚事情是如何发生的，是每位家长的责任。”对这起致命坠机事故原因的调查由德国联邦飞机事故调查局牵头。
They were assisted by representatives from both Russia and the United States, as the incident involved planes built in their respective countries. Initial considerations as to how such a rare catastrophe could occur centered around the presumption that one of the pilots must have somehow lost control mid-flight and directed their plane into the other. Post-mortem examinations of the Tupolev and Boeing crew members ruled each person's cause of death as a direct result of the collision. There were no indications that any suffered from pre-existing afflictions, physiological impairments, or psychological illnesses that may have contributed to the crash. Tests were conducted for the presence of alcohol, medication, or other drugs, but produced negative results in all cases. The possibility that exhaustion played a part was ruled out, as crew members had sufficient time to rest and relax prior to the flights. The German Meteorological Service reported the weather on the evening of July 1 was unremarkable, characterised by scattered cloud coverage with slight to moderate rain. Five other aircrafts flew above southern Germany that evening. Their crews reported seeing stars clearly, indicating visibility was good.
由于事件涉及在各自国家制造的飞机，他们得到了来自俄罗斯和美国代表的协助。关于这样一场罕见的灾难是如何发生的，最初的考量集中在一种假设上，即其中一名飞行员一定在飞行途中以某种方式失去了控制，并将他们的飞机撞向了另一架飞机。对图波列夫和波音机组人员的验尸结果排除了每个人死于碰撞直接结果之外的其他原因。没有迹象表明任何人患有预先存在的疾病、生理机能受损或心理疾病，这些因素本可能导致坠机。进行了是否存在酒精、药物或其他药物的测试，但在所有情况下结果均为阴性。疲劳起到了一定作用的可能性也被排除在外，因为机组人员在飞行前有充足的时间休息和放松。德国气象局报告称，7 月 1 日晚上的天气并无异常，特点是零星云层覆盖伴有小到中雨。当晚还有另外五架飞机在德国南部上空飞行。他们的机组人员报告说能清晰看到星星，这表明能见度很好。
However, they recalled a lack of moonlight around the time of the collision. This detail was confirmed by German military geophysicists, whose astronomical data revealed that although night had fallen, the moon was in the waning phase below the horizon and had not yet risen. This meant the night sky was particularly dark, limiting visibility from the cockpit to less than 10km ahead. As enquiries continued in Germany, investigations were also underway in Russia, Italy and Switzerland, countries that doomed flights had traversed during July 1. At the time of the collision, both planes were under the observation of Swiss-based air navigation service provider called Skyguide, which was tasked with supervising airspace over Lake Constance. The multi-million dollar company operated from an area control centre located inside a tall, windowed tower on the grounds of Zurich International Airport in the country's northeast. Investigators spoke with the Skyguide staff on duty the night of July 1, who reported an unusual occurrence at around 9.30pm. An air traffic controller was observing a navigation radar screen featuring a basic grid-like display of Swiss airspace and its surrounds.
然而，他们回忆起在相撞时缺乏月光。德国军事地球物理学家证实了这一细节，他们的天文数据表明，尽管夜幕已经降临，但月亮正处于地平线以下的残月阶段，尚未升起。这意味着夜空格外黑暗，将驾驶舱的能见度限制在前方不到 10 公里。随着德国调查的继续，俄罗斯、意大利和瑞士也在进行调查，这些国家是这趟注定失败的航班在 7 月 1 日期间穿过的。在相撞时，两架飞机都在瑞士空中导航服务提供商 Skyguide 的监视之下，该公司负责监督博登湖上空的空域。这家价值数百万美元的公司在一个区域控制中心运营，该中心位于瑞士东北部苏黎世国际机场地面上一座高耸的有窗塔楼内。调查人员与 7 月 1 日晚值班的 Skyguide 员工进行了交谈，他们报告称在晚上 9 点 30 分左右发生了一起异常事件。一名空中交通管制员正在观察一个导航雷达屏幕，上面显示着瑞士空域及其周边的基本网格状显示。
Small blips indicated aircraft positions in the sky, along with their flight number designation, altitude and approximate travelling speed. The controller noticed the blips of flights BTC 2937 and DHX 611 were rapidly approaching the same location over Lake Constance, both soaring at 36,000 feet. The controller presumed the situation was one of loss of separation, wherein aircrafts incidentally fly too close to one another. These aviation near misses are more common than most realise, but very rarely and in disaster. To remedy the loss of separation between flights BTC 2937 and DHX 611, the controller followed established procedures and radioed through to the Tupolev's cockpit, ordering Captain Alexander Gross to descend his aircraft by 1,000 feet. No radio communications were initiated by air traffic control to the Boeing aircraft. The only requirement to secure a safe passage of both flights was simply for one plane to move out of the way of the other. Strangely, there was no response from the Tupolev crew.
屏幕上的小光点显示了天空中飞机的位置，以及它们的航班号代号、高度和大致飞行速度。管制员注意到 BTC 2937 和 DHX 611 航班的光点正在博登湖上空迅速接近同一地点，两者都在 36,000 英尺的高空翱翔。管制员推测这种情况属于间隔丢失，即飞机偶然飞得彼此太近。这种航空近距离遭遇比大多数人意识到的更为常见，但演变成灾难的情况却极其罕见。为了补救 BTC 2937 和 DHX 611 航班之间的间隔丢失，管制员遵循既定程序，通过无线电呼叫图波列夫的驾驶舱，命令亚历山大·格罗斯机长将飞机下降 1,000 英尺。空中交通管制部门没有对波音飞机发起任何无线电通讯。确保两架航班安全通行的唯一要求，仅仅是一架飞机避开另一架飞机。奇怪的是，图波列夫机组人员没有任何回应。
The controller repeated his demand, this time with more emphasis. Captain Alexander Gross's voice finally came through the radio, clarifying the order to descend, which the controller confirmed. The controller was under the impression the Tupolev crew had followed through with the descent and the crisis had been averted. It wasn't until the blips of flights BTC 2937 and DHX 611 suddenly disappeared from navigation radar screens that Skyguide staff realised something wasn't right. Attempts to re-establish radio communications with the Tupolev cockpit crew were met with silence. Skyguide officials could offer no explanation as to why the two planes had collided. According to the company, the Tupolev was ordered to descend about two minutes before the crash, giving the airliner ample time to safely move out of the Boeing's flight path. A representative from Skyguide informed the media, quote,
管制员重复了他的要求，这次语气更加强调。亚历山大·格罗斯机长的声音终于通过无线电传了过来，澄清了下降的指令，管制员对此进行了确认。管制员当时以为图波列夫机组人员已经执行了下降指令，危机已经化解。直到 BTC 2937 和 DHX 611 航班的光点突然从导航雷达屏幕上消失，Skyguide 员工才意识到情况不对劲。重新建立与图波列夫驾驶舱机组人员无线电通讯的尝试均以沉默告终。Skyguide 官员无法解释这两架飞机为什么会相撞。据该公司称，图波列夫在坠机前约两分钟接到下降命令，这给了这架客机充足的时间安全地移出波音的飞行路径。一位 Skyguide 的代表向媒体通报说，引述道：
The problem was that the Russian plane did not immediately respond for reasons that aren't entirely clear. These comments led to speculation as to whether the Tupolev crew's initial inaction was to blame for the tragedy and whether it was intentional or not. Bashkirian Airlines were quick to come to the defence of their crew, insisting all staff on board were highly qualified and experienced. In the Russian Federation, flight crews are awarded performance classes based on their qualifications and flight skill. There are four in total, class one being the highest. All the Tupolev crew members were class one. Furthermore, Captain Alexander Gross was experienced in navigating difficult flight conditions that required last minute manoeuvres. During one particularly problematic flight to Budapest, unpredictable weather had him descending onto an airstrip that had been flooded by an overflowing river. He successfully brought the plane down safely, receiving applause from his relieved and grateful passengers.
问题在于，由于并非完全清楚的原因，俄罗斯飞机没有立即做出回应。这些评论引发了人们的猜测，即图波列夫机组人员最初的不作为是否应该为这场悲剧负责，以及这是故意的还是无意的。巴什科尔托斯坦航空迅速站出来为他们的机组人员辩护，坚信机组所有人员都具备高度的资质和经验。在俄罗斯联邦，机组人员根据其资格和飞行技能被授予飞行性能等级。总共有四个等级，一级为最高。所有图波列夫机组人员都是一级。此外，亚历山大·格罗斯机长经验丰富，能够驾驭需要临时机动的困难飞行条件。在一次飞往布达佩斯的特别棘手的飞行中，变幻莫测的天气使他降落在被泛滥的河流淹没的简易跑道上。他成功地将飞机安全降落，赢得了如释重负且充满感激的乘客们的掌声。
The seasoned captain was known to abide by a single rule when flying. He refused to relax, as there were 150 people behind his back depending on him. Nevertheless, Alexander's immediate inaction prior to the uberling and mid-air collision raised many questions. The theory that the Russian crew was at fault gained momentum, with rumours spreading that they may not have fully understood the English commands given by Skyguides air traffic controller, despite it being the de facto international language of civil aviation. Wanting to dispel the accusations directed towards her husband, Alexander's widow came forward to present a certificate he had been issued years prior, acknowledging his extensive knowledge and understanding of English flight language. Blame and criticism were further spotlighted on Russia, when aviation officials labelled Tupolev aircrafts as careless. Boeing airliners had made its name as one of the most reliable aircrafts, with a generally good safety record. However, Russia's ageing domestic workhorse the Tupolev had a checkered history.
这位经验丰富的机长在飞行时以遵守一条规则而闻名。他拒绝放松，因为他的身后有 150 人依赖着他。尽管如此，在乌伯林根空中相撞之前，亚历山大立即的不作为引发了许多疑问。认为俄罗斯机组人员有过错的理论开始获得动力，有传言称他们可能没有完全理解 Skyguide 空中交通管制员给出的英语指令，尽管英语是民用航空事实上国际通用语言。为了消除针对她丈夫的指责，亚历山大的遗孀出面展示了他多年前颁发的一份证书，承认他对英语飞行语言有广泛的知识和理解。当航空官员将图波列夫飞机贴上粗心大意的标签时，责备和批评进一步集中到了俄罗斯身上。波音客机以其普遍良好的安全记录赢得了最可靠飞机之一的名声。然而，俄罗斯老化的国内主力图波列夫却有着一段复杂的历史。
Although a popular aircraft, it had been involved in about 30 air disasters since its inception. Months prior to the uberling and mid-air collision, a Tupolev exploded in mid-air and crashed into the Black Sea, killing 78 passengers and crew. Months before that, a Tupolev crashed in Siberia, killing 143 people on board. Additional crashes in China, Namibia and the United Arab Emirates claimed the lives of a further 300 people. Experts blamed poor maintenance, safety violations and cost cutting for the high accident rate. Yet, record showed the Tupolev involved in the uberling and mid-air collision had received a technical inspection on June 28, 2002, just two days before the fatal crash. The plane was determined to be in fine working order with no technical defects and received authorization to fly. Similar inspections were carried out on the Boeing, the last occurring just over two months prior to the crash.
尽管图波列夫是一款受欢迎的飞机，但自问世以来，它已经卷入了大约30起空难。在乌伯lingen空中相撞事件发生的几个月前，一架图波列夫在空中爆炸并坠入黑海，导致78名乘客和机组人员遇难。而在几个月前，另一架图波列夫在西伯利亚坠毁，机上143人丧生。中国、纳米比亚和阿拉伯联合酋长国的其他坠机事件又夺去了300多人的生命。专家将高事故率归咎于维护不善、违反安全规定以及削减成本。然而，记录显示，卷入乌伯lingen空中相撞事件的那架图波列夫在2002年6月28日刚刚接受过技术检查，也就是致命坠机发生前仅仅两天。飞机被确定工作状态良好，没有技术缺陷，并获得了飞行许可。波音飞机也进行了类似的检查，最近一次是在坠机前两个多月进行的。
It too was given the all-clear. The head of Bashkirian Airlines stressed the Tupolev met all requirements set by the International Civil Aviation Organization and dissipated accusations mounting against the Russian crew. He insisted to reporters. There were no reasons to say that the pilots didn't handle the plane properly. Switzerland's President, Kaspar Villiger, was scheduled to attend a public memorial service held in Ulfa to honor the victims of the crash. However, he was forced to cancel plans when Russian authorities were unable to guarantee his safety. Emotions were running high in proud and nationalistic Russia. Local anger was directed towards the Swiss, who had failed to send condolences immediately following the crash. In another perceived transgression, Swiss officials and media had defied ethical standards by immediately placing the blame on the Russian pilots and aircraft, despite the ongoing investigation having drawn no such conclusions.
它同样被准许放行。巴什科尔托斯坦航空公司的负责人强调，这架图波列夫符合国际民用航空组织制定的所有要求，并驳斥了针对俄罗斯机组人员不断增加的指责。他向记者坚称，没有任何理由说飞行员没有妥善操控飞机。瑞士总统卡斯帕·维利格原本计划前往乌法参加公开追悼会，以悼念空难遇难者。然而，由于俄罗斯当局无法保证他的安全，他被迫取消了计划。在骄傲且具有民族主义情绪的俄罗斯，情绪异常高涨。当地的愤怒情绪指向了瑞士，因为他们在坠机后未能立即表示哀悼。在另一次被认为越轨的行为中，尽管正在进行的调查尚未得出此类结论，但瑞士官员和媒体却无视伦理标准，立即将责任归咎于俄罗斯飞行员和飞机。
Hundreds of Russian citizens greeted the coffins carrying the remains of the 45 schoolchildren upon their arrival to Ulfa Airport. They were taken to Gostini Dvor Square for a public memorial, the usually vibrant plaza serving as a gathering spot for the heartbroken community to come together and grieve. The German Deputy Foreign Minister attended the service and told the crowd, We will never forget our compatriots, German people crying together with Russians at the side of a charred wheat field. He promised to erect a memorial at the crash site to serve as an eternal remembrance. After the service, the coffins were placed on the buses and taken to a cemetery in southern Ulfa. Portraits of each student were displayed in the windows as mourners framed the procession route, tossing flowers onto the road as the vehicles approached. The students were buried together, their headstones placed in rows resembling their seating pattern on flight BTC 2937.
数百名俄罗斯公民在乌法机场迎接装载着45名学童遗体的棺木。遗体被运往戈斯蒂尼·德沃尔广场举行公众悼念活动，平日里充满生机的广场此刻成了心碎的社区聚集在一起共同哀悼的场所。德国副外交部长出席了仪式并对人群说，我们将永远不会忘记我们的同胞，德国人民在焦黑的麦田旁与俄罗斯人同悲。他承诺在坠机地点建立一座纪念碑，作为永远的怀念。仪式结束后，棺木被抬上巴士，运往乌法南部的一座公墓。每个学生的肖像都展示在车窗上，哀悼者在送葬路线两侧排起长队，当车辆驶近时，向路上抛洒鲜花。学生们被埋葬在一起，他们的墓碑排列成行，如同他们在BTC 2937航班上的座位排列方式。
The local government organized a special fund of 28 million rubles for the families of the victims, but it came with the understanding that no amount of money could compensate for the immense loss. Condolences were offered on behalf of Russia's President Vladimir Putin, who said, And they left us as angels for heaven. Ongoing searches of the extensive crash site resulted in the discovery of two distinct red-coloured devices, the flight recorders of both aircraft, informally known as the black boxes. Engineered to withstand conditions arising from aircraft destruction, they facilitate the investigation of aviation accidents. They consist of a single unit made up of two individual devices. One is the flight data recorder, which preserves the recent history of the flight's internal electronic systems, including control inputs and engine information. The other is the cockpit voice recorder, which records the audio environment within, including conversations between crew members.
当地政府为遇难者家属组织了一项2800万卢布的专项基金，但大家都明白，再多的钱也无法弥补巨大的损失。俄罗斯总统弗拉基米尔·普京也致以慰问，他表示：“他们作为天使离开了我们，去了天堂。”对广阔坠机地点的持续搜寻发现了两个截然不同的红色设备，即两架飞机的飞行记录仪，俗称黑匣子。它们旨在承受飞机毁灭所产生的极端条件，有助于对航空事故进行调查。它们由一个包含两个独立设备的单一单元组成。一个是飞行记录仪，它保存了飞行内部电子系统的近期历史记录，包括控制输入和发动机信息。另一个是驾驶舱语音记录仪，它记录内部的音频环境，包括机组人员之间的对话。
As experts began the intricate process of retrieving the data stored on the flight reporters, key pieces of the Tupolev and Boeing were transported to a specialized storage hangar for further examination. Efforts to determine how the collision transpired by reconstructing the aircrafts were hampered by the sheer state of their destruction, with many vital parts having been completely destroyed and never recovered. Nevertheless, the wreckage coupled with the flight recorder data would provide an invaluable resource in understanding how the rare catastrophe transpired. On the fifth day of the investigation, examiners collated the information gathered from the wreckage with the data from the flight recorders and presented their findings, revealing the sequence of events that led to the Uberlingen mid-air collision on July 1, 2002. Following their intermediate landing in Italy, DHL cargo flight DHX 611 was travelling north towards Belgium. At 9.21pm, the plane was flying over the snow-capped Alpine region of southern Switzerland when Captain Paul Phillips initiated radio communications with air traffic control, requesting clearance to climb to a higher altitude, as the thinner air above provided less resistance and preserved fuel. He specifically requested to rise to 36,000 feet. By this point, the Boeing was in Skyguide's jurisdiction, and Captain Phillips' radio message reached the company's Zurich-based air control centre, where his request was granted.
当专家们开始对存储在飞行记录仪上的数据进行复杂的提取过程时，图波列夫和波音的关键部件被运送到一个专门的储藏机库作进一步检查。由于飞机损毁极其严重，许多至关重要的部件被完全摧毁且从未找到，这阻碍了通过重建飞机来确定碰撞如何发生的工作。尽管如此，残骸加上飞行记录仪的数据将为理解这场罕见灾难是如何发生的提供宝贵的资源。在调查的第五天，检查员将从残骸中收集的信息与飞行记录仪的数据进行了比对，并公布了他们的发现，揭示了导致2002年7月1日乌伯lingen空中相撞事件的一系列事件。在意大利经停后，DHL货运航班DHX 611正向北飞往比利时。晚上9点21分，这架飞机正飞越瑞士南部白雪皑皑的高山地区，机长保罗·菲利普斯启动了与空中交通管制的无线电通信，请求准许爬升到更高的高度，因为上方较稀薄的空气阻力较小并能节省燃料。他具体请求上升到36,000英尺。此时，这架波音飞机正处于瑞士空管公司的管辖范围内，机长菲利普斯的无线电信息传到了该公司位于苏黎世的空中控制中心，并获得了批准。
15 minutes later, First Officer Brandt Campione left his seat to attend the lavatory installed in a cubicle at the rear of the cockpit, leaving Paul Phillips alone at the controls. 14 seconds later, an alarm began emanating from the control panel. It was accompanied by a monotone, automated voice repeating the words, traffic, traffic. The automated voice arose from the aircraft's inbuilt traffic collision avoidance system. Informally referred to as TCAS, the relatively new technology listened in on the constant stream of radio signals radiating from commercial aircrafts and calculated whether any were on a collision course. If they were, the system would issue a warning, and if necessary, inform pilots of what action to take to avoid one another. When the TCAS issued this course of action, known as a resolution advisory, the pilot had been trained to respond immediately, and manoeuvre is indicated, unless they knew doing so would jeopardise the safe operation of the flight. Both the Tupolev and the Boeing had TCAS installed. Experts understood that had the system worked as it was designed to, the Uberling and mid-air collision should never had occurred. This raised the possibility that it might have malfunctioned, or issued an error.
15分钟后，副驾驶布兰特·坎皮奥尼离开座位，去驾驶舱后部的洗手间，留下保罗·菲利普斯独自控制飞机。14秒后，控制面板发出警报。伴随着单调的、自动的声音，重复着“交通，交通”这个词。这个自动声音来自飞机内置的空中防撞系统。该技术通常被称为TCAS，这项相对较新的技术监听来自商用飞机的源源不断的无线电信号流，并计算是否有飞机处于相撞航线上。如果有，系统会发出警告，并在必要时通知飞行员采取什么行动以避免碰撞。当TCAS发出这种被称为分辨率建议的行动方案时，飞行员已经接受过立即响应的训练，并按照指示进行机动，除非他们知道这样做会危及飞行的安全操作。图波列夫和波音都安装了TCAS。专家们明白，如果该系统按照设计运作，乌伯lingen空中相撞事件本不应该发生。这引发了一种可能性，即它可能发生故障或发出了错误指令。
14 seconds after, Captain Paul Phillips was alerted by TCAS of nearby traffic. The system issued a resolution advisory. The automated voice directed the pilot to descend, descend. Remaining calm, Captain Phillips pushed the control column forwards, tilting the plane downwards as per instruction. The TCAS then advised, increase descent, increase descent. At this point, Brent Campioni had returned from the lavatory and resumed his position at the controls. Upon hearing the TCAS alert, Brent told the captain to increase, and the Boeing's rate of descent was escalated. The pair were unable to make visual contact of any nearby aircraft due to the sheer darkness beyond the windshield. Captain Phillips attempted to establish radio communications with Swiss air traffic control to determine who or what was in their proximity, but his messages weren't unanswered. Several kilometres away, Bashkirian Airlines flight BTC 2937 was soaring towards the Germany-Switzerland border at a cruising altitude of 36,000 feet. As the Tupolev approached airspace over Lake Constance, its TCAS issued an alert warning that another aircraft was within close proximity.
14秒后，机长保罗·菲利普斯收到TCAS关于附近交通的警报。系统发出了分辨率建议。自动语音指挥飞行员下降，下降。保持冷静，机长菲利普斯向前推操纵杆，按照指示将飞机向下倾斜。TCAS随后建议，增加下降，增加下降。此时，布伦特·坎皮尼已经从洗手间回来，并恢复了对控制器的操作。听到TCAS警报后，布伦特告诉机长增加速度，波音的下降率随之加快。由于挡风玻璃外的黑暗一片，两人无法用肉眼看到任何附近的飞机。机长菲利普斯试图与瑞士空中交通管制建立无线电通信，以确定谁或什么在他们附近，但他的信息没有得到回应。几公里外，巴什科尔托斯坦航空公司BTC 2937航班正以36,000英尺的巡航高度向德国-瑞士边境飞去。当图波列夫接近博登湖上空的空域时，其TCAS发出警报，警告有另一架飞机在附近。
Seven seconds later, the crew received radio communications from Zurich based air traffic control, ordering them to descend due to crossing traffic. The message prompted discussions between the crew members as they observed the night sky for the other aircraft. Although no one verbally responded to the controller, lingering accusations that Captain Alexander Gross did not understand to the commands given to him in English were dispelled, as instrument data indicated he followed through with the descent. Suddenly, TCAS generated a resolution advisory, commanding the pilot to instead... Climb. Climb. Off-duty First Officer Murat Idkulov acknowledged the TCAS, telling the others it says climb. His unease was brushed aside by Oleg Grigoryev, the most senior member of the crew and to the pilot in command.
七秒钟后，机组人员接到来自苏黎世空中交通管制的无线电通信，由于交叉交通，命令他们下降。这条消息促使机组成员在观察夜空寻找另一架飞机时进行了讨论。尽管没有人用言语回应管制员，但残存的指责亚历山大·格罗斯机长听不懂用英语发出的指令的说法被打消了，因为仪器数据显示他确实执行了下降操作。突然，TCAS生成了分辨率建议，指挥飞行员改为……爬升。爬升。休班副驾驶穆拉特·伊德库洛夫承认了TCAS，告诉其他人它说爬升。他的不安被奥列格·格里戈里耶夫（机组成员中资历最高的人兼机长）忽视了。
Oleg indicated they should follow instructions provided by the air traffic controller, saying, he is guiding us down. Murat disagreed, certain they should adhere to TCAS and descend. Debate erupted in the cockpit between crew members as they disputed what course of action to take. The confusion prompted Captain Gross to halt the descent. But then, air traffic control radioed through a second message, repeating their order to expedite the descent. Captain Gross tentatively recited the order back to the controller, who quickly replied, Yes, we have traffic at your two o'clock. With this confirmation, Captain Gross committed to the descent.
奥列格示意他们应该遵循空中交通管制员提供的指令，说：“他在引导我们向下。”穆拉特表示不同意，确信他们应该坚持TCAS并下降。驾驶舱内机组成员之间爆发了争论，他们争论该采取什么行动方案。混乱促使格罗斯机长停止了下降。但随后，空中交通管制通过无线电发出了第二条消息，重复了他们加快下降的命令。格罗斯机长试探性地向管制员复述了这条命令，管制员迅速回答：“是的，我们两点钟方向有交通。”得到这个确认后，格罗斯机长决定继续下降。
The Tupolev crew nervously observed the night sky in the two o'clock direction, waiting to spot the approaching aircraft. Oleg Grigoryev asked frantically, Where is it? The panicked voice of Murat Kulov responded, Here, on the left side. The inbound aircraft was not in the two o'clock position as advised by air traffic control, but on the opposite side of the Tupolev, in the ten o'clock position. The Tupolev's flight navigator explained, It's going to pass beneath us, as TCAS issued another resolution advisory, Instructing the pilot to, Increase climb, Increase climb. It was too late.
图波列夫机组人员紧张地观察着两点钟方向的夜空，等待发现正在接近的飞机。奥列格·格里戈里耶夫疯狂地问：“它在哪里？”穆拉特·库洛夫惊慌失措的声音回答：“在这里，在左边。”迎面而来的飞机不在空中交通管制建议的两点钟位置，而是在图波列夫的反方向，即十点钟位置。图波列夫的飞行领航员解释说：“它将从我们下方通过，”此时TCAS发出了另一项分辨率建议，指示飞行员“增加爬升，增加爬升”。太迟了。
The Tupolev was in steep descent above the Boeing, where pilots Brant Campioni and Captain Paul Phillips were obeying the orders of their TCAS. Suddenly, the pair caught sight of the Tupolev right above them, causing Brant to remark in shock, Traffic, right there. He desperately ordered Captain Phillips to, Descend hard. There was insufficient time for either aircraft to maneuver out of the other's way, And at 9.35pm, they collided in the airspace over southern Germany. The Boeing flew underneath the Tupolev, its rear vertical tail clipped the left wing of the passenger airliner, Before slicing through its fuselage and severing it in half.
图波列夫在波音上方急剧下降，飞行员布兰特·坎皮奥尼和机长保罗·菲利普斯正在服从TCAS的指令。突然，两人发现图波列夫就在他们正上方，布兰特震惊地评论道：“交通，就在那里。”他拼命命令机长菲利普斯：“狠狠下降。”两架飞机都没有足够的时间做机动动作以避开对方，晚上9点35分，它们在德国南部上空相撞。波音从图波列夫下方飞过，其后垂直尾翼刮擦了客机的左翼，然后切过其机身并将其切成两半。
An explosive decompression expelled all oxygen within the cabin, rendering all those on board unconscious within seconds. The airliner continued to break up in midair, raining pieces of fractured metal onto the town of Wolvingen below. The impact sheared 80% of the Boeing's vertical tail, leaving nothing more than a stump and causing the aircraft to become aerodynamically unstable. Rolling about its longitudinal axis, the Boeing then lost use of the engines due to the higher lateral forces. Unable to control their aircraft, Paul Phillips and Brant Campioni endured an agonizing 3 minute descent as their plane plummeted to Earth. The findings clarified that neither the aircraft crews nor a faulty traffic collision avoidance system were responsible for the collision. The T-Cass had worked just as it was designed to. Upon calculating the flight's DHX-611 and BTC-2937 were on a collision course, the system issued prompt resolutions to rectify the problem,
爆炸性减压排出了客舱内的所有氧气，使机上所有人几秒钟内失去知觉。客机继续在空中解体，将破碎的金属碎片像雨点般洒向下方的沃尔文根镇。撞击剪断了波音公司80%的垂直尾翼，只留下一个残桩，导致飞机空气动力学不稳定。围绕其纵轴滚动后，由于较高的侧向力，波音失去了发动机的使用权。无法控制他们的飞机，保罗·菲利普斯和布兰特·坎皮奥尼忍受了痛苦的3分钟下降，因为他们的飞机坠向地球。调查结果澄清说，飞机机组人员和有故障的空中防撞系统均不对碰撞负责。TCAS完全按照设计运作。在计算出DHX-611和BTC-2937航班处于相撞航线上后，系统发出了迅速的解决方案以纠正问题，
Ordering the Boeing to descend and the Tupolev to climb. Had the crews followed these instructions, the collision would have been avoided. However, Skyguide air traffic control issued the Tupolev crew with conflicting orders, instructing them to descend instead and subsequently bringing the passenger plane down on top of the Boeing. Skyguide staff had initially informed investigators that orders were given to the Tupolev two minutes before the collision. This statement was deemed false when transcripts of radio communications between the Tupolev and Skyguide revealed the first radioed order was given a mere 43 seconds before impact, An insufficient time frame for them to adjust their altitude for safe passage. Still, this didn't answer the pressing question as to why the air traffic controller provided the Tupolev crew with misguided or miscalculated instructions. Investigations narrowed in on the air traffic controller who gave the fatal directions.
命令波音下降，图波列夫爬升。如果机组人员遵循这些指示，碰撞本可以避免。然而，Skyguide空中交通管制向图波列夫机组人员发出了相互矛盾的指令，指示他们改为下降，随后将客机带到了波音上方。Skyguide工作人员最初通知调查人员，在相撞前两分钟向图波列夫发出了指令。当图波列夫和Skyguide之间的无线电通信记录显示第一次无线电指令在撞击前仅43秒发出时，这一说法被认为是虚假的，没有给他们足够的时间来调整高度以安全通过。尽管如此，这并没有回答一个紧迫的问题，即为什么空中交通管制员会向图波列夫机组人员提供误导或计算错误的指令。调查范围缩小到发出致命指令的空中交通管制员身上。
The controller's 10-year career history was scrupulously studied, only to reveal a worker considered by workmates and supervisors as competent and knowledgeable, with a professional and cooperative attitude. Nothing in his records indicated deficiencies in his skill or experience. However, in May of 2001, a year before the Uberlingen mid-air collision, the controller was involved in a similar loss of separation incident. No one was harmed in that instance, but a subsequent investigation attributed the incident in part to the controller's error in judgement in evaluating the space required to safely conduct an altitude crossing manoeuvre. Following this, Skyguide conducted a 30-minute debrief with the controller, but the contents of this session were not documented and didn't lead the company to form any serious concerns about the controller's ability. It was considered an isolated incident in an otherwise unblemished career. On the morning following the Uberlingen mid-air collision, investigators collected blood and urine samples from the Skyguide staff who were on duty the night prior, including the controller in question. Subsequent testing of these samples for drugs, alcohol and medication produced negative results, confirming the controller was not under the influence of any substance that may have impacted their capability on the night of July 1.
对该管制员10年的职业生涯进行了严格的研究，结果只显示他是一名被同事和主管认为称职、知识渊博、具有专业和合作态度的员工。他的记录中没有任何迹象表明他的技能或经验有缺陷。然而，在2001年5月，即乌伯lingen空中相撞事件发生前一年，该管制员卷入了一起类似的垂直间隔丢失事件。在那次事件中没有人受伤，但随后的调查部分归咎于该管制员在评估安全进行高度交叉机动所需空间时的判断错误。在此之后，Skyguide对该管制员进行了30分钟的汇报，但这次会议的内容没有记录，也没有导致该公司对该管制员的能力产生任何严重担忧。在一段原本无瑕疵的职业生涯中，这被认为是一起孤立事件。在乌伯lingen空中相撞事件发生后的早晨，调查人员收集了前一天晚上值班的Skyguide工作人员（包括涉事管制员）的血液和尿液样本。随后对这些样本进行的药物、酒精和药物测试结果呈阴性，证实该管制员在7月1日晚上没有受任何可能影响其能力的物质的影响。
The actions of the air traffic controller were released to the media, who labelled him a mass murderer. For his own safety, his name and identity were never released to the public. Hate Mail flooded Skyguide's corporate offices as the company refused to offer an explanation or apology for the crash. Swiss authorities opened an investigation to determine whether the controller was indeed responsible and whether there was enough evidence to charge him with 71 cases of negligent manslaughter. During an interview with German press shortly after the disaster, the controller admitted to his role in the catastrophe, explaining, quote, On the night of the accident, I was part of a network of people, computers, monitoring into transmission devices and regulations. All these parts must work together seamlessly and without error, and they must be synchronised. As an air traffic controller, it is my task and duty to prevent such accidents.
空中交通管制员的行为被公之于众，媒体称他为“大众杀手”。为了他自身的安全，他的名字和身份从未向公众公开。仇恨邮件涌入了Skyguide的公司办公室，因为该公司拒绝为坠机事件提供解释或道歉。瑞士当局展开调查，以确定该管制员是否确实负有责任，以及是否有足够的证据指控他71项过失杀人罪。在灾难发生后不久接受德国媒体采访时，该管制员承认了自己在灾难中的角色，解释说：“在事故当晚，我是由人、计算机、监控传输设备和法规组成网络的一部分。所有这些部分必须无缝协作且不出错误，并且它们必须同步。作为一名空中交通管制员，我的任务和责任是防止此类事故发生。”
So many children lost their lives, and so many hopes for the future were erased. When these comments went to print, the air traffic controller was referred to simply as Peter Renn. Although the job of a pilot is to get airline cargo or passengers to their destination, it is the work conducted by air traffic controllers that ensures the planes arrive safely. Their role is to monitor airspace from control towers on the ground, observing radar screens whilst providing direction and assistance to pilots via radio for the safe, efficient and orderly flow of air traffic. As such, air traffic control is regarded as one of the most mentally challenging and stressful professions, involving real-time decision-making based on changing flight plans, unexpected weather conditions, unscheduled traffic and emergency situations. For the most part, it is the often unrecognised work performed by air traffic controllers that makes flying such a low-risk endeavour and one of the safest modes of transportation. Each controller is carefully selected, highly trained and rigorously tested before being granted with a licence to conduct air traffic navigation. In March 1994, Peter Nielsen successfully completed his training to become an air traffic controller and was granted his licence by the Norwegian Civil Aviation Administration.
太多儿童失去了生命，太多对未来的希望被抹去。当这些评论被印刷出来时，这位空中交通管制员被简称为彼得·雷恩（Peter Renn）。尽管飞行员的工作是将航空货物或乘客送达目的地，但确保飞机安全抵达的是空中交通管制员的工作。他们的职责是从地面的控制塔监控空域，观察雷达屏幕，同时通过无线电向飞行员提供方向和协助，以实现空中交通的安全、高效和有序流动。因此，空中交通管制被认为是精神上最具挑战性和压力的职业之一，涉及根据不断变化的飞行计划、意外天气条件、未安排的交通和紧急情况做出实时决策。在很大程度上，正是空中交通管制员经常不被认可的工作，才使得飞行成为一项低风险的事业和最安全的交通方式之一。每位管制员在获得空中交通导航执照之前都要经过精心挑选、严格培训和严格测试。1994年3月，彼得·尼尔森成功完成了培训，成为一名空中交通管制员，并获得了挪威民航局颁发的执照。
Peter worked within his home country of Denmark until 1995, before moving to Switzerland with his wife, Metta. They settled in the leafy suburb of Kloten about 10km north of Zurich, where they raised three children. Metta's 13-year-old teenage son and the couple's younger children aged 4 and 2. The Nielsen's home suburb overlooked Zurich International Airport, where Peter began working for Skyguide in their area control centre. By mid-2002, 36-year-old Peter Nielsen was highly competent in aviation management, with nearly 10 years of experience under his belt. It was a challenging and stressful career, but Peter channelled the pressure he faced at work into recreational fitness. He loved to run and swim, but his favourite sport was ice hockey. Every Wednesday, Peter would meet with a group of his work colleagues who had formed their own ice hockey team, and together they'd blow off steam by skating around the rink. In the early hours of July 1, 2002, Peter Nielsen arrived to work and settled in for a quiet night.
彼得在他的祖国丹麦工作到1995年，之后与妻子梅塔移居瑞士。他们在苏黎世以北约10公里处绿树成荫的克洛滕郊区定居，并养育了三个孩子。梅塔13岁的继子以及这对夫妇4岁和2岁的小孩子。尼尔森一家的住所俯瞰着苏黎世国际机场，彼得开始在那里为Skyguide的区域控制中心工作。到2002年中期，36岁的彼得·尼尔森在航空管理方面非常能干，拥有近10年的经验。这是一份具有挑战性和压力的职业，但彼得将他在工作中面临的压力转化为娱乐健身。他喜欢跑步和游泳，但他最喜欢的运动是冰球。每周三，彼得都会与一群组建了自己的冰球队伍的同事见面，他们一起在溜冰场滑冰来发泄压力。2002年7月1日凌晨，彼得·尼尔森上班并安顿下来准备度过一个安静的夜晚。
By day, the centralised airspace over Switzerland was one of the busiest crossroads in Europe. Yet the late hours saw a dramatic reduction in the number of inbound and outbound flights, with only a few aircrafts moving through the sky at any given time. This reduction was due in part to an imposed curfew that forced the Zurich airport to close their runways to wind coming or outgoing flights overnight. Later that evening, when news reached Skyguides Area Control Centre that two commercial airliners had collided in mid-air within their jurisdiction, staff were left shocked. They were even more surprised to learn the accident occurred whilst the flights were being monitored by seasoned and well-regarded air traffic controller Peter Nielsen. When Peter learned he was under a criminal investigation in relation to the crash, he suffered a mental breakdown that required hospitalisation and psychiatric treatment. He claimed that due to the immense trauma he had suffered over the incident, he couldn't remember anything about the moments leading up to the catastrophe. Investigations into his conduct continued for months, as authorities carefully pieced together what evidence they could to determine the extent of Peter Nielsen's culpability.
白天，瑞士集中的空域是欧洲最繁忙的十字路口之一。然而到了深夜，进出港航班数量急剧减少，任何时候都只有几架飞机在空中穿行。这种减少部分归因于实施的宵禁，该宵禁迫使苏黎世机场在夜间对迎面而来或离开的航班关闭跑道。那天晚上晚些时候，当消息传到Skyguide区域控制中心，称两架商用客机在其管辖范围内在空中相撞时，工作人员感到震惊。当他们得知这起事故是在经验丰富、备受尊崇的空中交通管制员彼得·尼尔森监控飞行时发生的，他们感到更加惊讶。当彼得得知自己因与坠机有关而受到刑事调查时，他精神崩溃，需要住院和精神病治疗。他声称，由于他在事件中遭受了巨大的创伤，他记不起灾难发生前的任何事情。对他的行为的调查持续了几个月，当局仔细拼凑他们能找到的证据，以确定彼得·尼尔森的罪责程度。
A year after the Uberling and mid-air collision, investigations were still underway to determine Peter Nielsen's role in the crash. His mental state had since improved, and after taking months off for treatment, he finally returned to work. He had since retired from his air traffic controller position and had taken up an office job at Skyguides Corporate Office, where he was involved in the development of air traffic projects. A vase containing a single white rose was on display at his former workstation in the area control centre, as a show of support from his old colleagues. Tuesday, February 24, 2004 marked one year and eight months since the Uberling and collision. It was approaching 5.45pm in the Swiss town of Clotun and getting dark outside, as the remnants of recently fallen snow slowly melted away. Peter was at home in his street level two-story pink washed suburban flat with his wife Metta and their young children. Peter and Metta were lying on the sofa together watching television.
乌伯lingen空中相撞事件发生一年后，调查仍在进行中，以确定彼得·尼尔森在坠机事件中的角色。他的精神状态此后有所改善，经过数月的治疗后，他终于重返工作岗位。他此后从空中交通管制员的职位上退休，并在Skyguide公司办公室担任了一份办公室工作，参与空中交通项目的开发。在他以前在区域控制中心的工作站上摆放着一个插有一朵白玫瑰的花瓶，以表达他老同事们对他的支持。2004年2月24日星期二，标志着乌伯lingen空中相撞事件已经过去了一年零八个月。瑞士小镇克洛滕的时间接近傍晚5点45分，外面天色渐暗，新近降落的雪的残余部分慢慢融化。彼得和他的妻子梅塔以及他们的幼童在家里的街道层两层粉红色水洗郊区公寓里。彼得和梅塔一起躺在沙发上看电视。
Needing to do some lining, Metta prepared to stand, but Peter urged her to stay put and enjoy the coziness. Eventually, Metta dragged herself away to do housework. At 5.51pm, Peter looked outside and noticed an unfamiliar man sitting alone on a garden seat on their front terrace. The stranger was unshaven, appeared to be aged in his 40s or 50s with a burly physique and dark hair with grey streaks. He was dressed in black with a long coat, holding a brown envelope. Peter told Metta of the man outside before making his way to the patio to greet him. As he headed out, Peter's youngest daughter ran towards him, but he shut the door behind him, causing the two-year-old to burst into tears. Metta led her daughter further into the house to comfort her.
需要熨烫一些衣服，梅塔准备站起来，但彼得敦促她留下来享受舒适。最终，梅塔把自己拖开去做家务。下午5点51分，彼得向外看去，注意到一个生面孔的男人独自坐在前露台的花园长椅上。这个陌生人没有刮胡子，看起来四十或五十岁，身材魁梧，黑发中夹杂着灰发。他穿着黑色长衣，拿着一个棕色信封。彼得把外面有人的事告诉了梅塔，然后朝露台走去迎接他。当他走出去时，彼得最小的女儿向他跑去，但他把门关上了，导致这个两岁的孩子放声大哭。梅塔把女儿带到屋里更深处去安慰她。
The voices of her husband and the man were barely audible from inside the house, but Metta could hear the stranger speaking in broken German with an Eastern European accent. A minute later, she heard him shout, I am Russia. A scream then erupted from Peter. Metta heard her husband yell, Don't kill me. Telling her children to stay put, Metta raced outside and found Peter lying on the terrace, covered in blood. He looked up at her and pleaded, call an ambulance. The dishevelled older man stood over him, a long knife in his hand, to be continued next week. To be continued... There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
从屋里几乎听不清她丈夫和那个男人的声音，但梅塔能听到那个陌生人用带着东欧口音的破碎德语说话。一分钟后，她听到他大喊：“我是俄罗斯人。”接着彼得发出了一声尖叫。梅塔听到她丈夫大喊：“别杀我。”告诉她的孩子们呆在原地，梅塔冲到外面，发现彼得躺在露台上，浑身是血。他抬头看着她并恳求道：“叫救护车。”衣衫褴褛的年长男子站在他身旁，手里拿着一把长刀，下周继续。待续……本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。